a typical customer service experience
requires
multiple conversational twists and turns
to achieve the required outcome
stick around to learn how dialogflow cx
simplifies a complex conversational
experience
hi i'm priyanka vergaria and in this
episode of deconstructing chatbots
we will help our friends at bugs
understand exactly how
a dialog flow cx conversation is defined
and visualized as a state machine
like any e-commerce company pugs has
customers that call in for ordering cute
dog shoes
and for returning or exchanging them as
you can imagine
each of these topics require multiple
conversational turns
for the virtual agent to acquire
necessary information
for that customer that's where flows
come in
flows are used to contain and control
the definition of these topics
and their associated conversational
paths here's how this works
every agent is automatically created
with one flow
called default start flow sometimes the
single flow may be all you need for a
simple agent
look at this example default start flow
here provides store hours store location
and helps place new orders but pog's
case
is a bit more complicated they have
different development teams handling
orders
returns and exchanges for situations
like this
agents require additional flows in this
case the default start flow which is
automatically created with the agent
leads to the three additional flows for
orders returns and
exchanges so the three teams can manage
them independently
and use the default start flow as a
single entry point into the conversation
now if we double click on any flow we
find that it's a collection of pages
which represent the state of the cx
session at any given moment
exactly one page is the current page and
the current page is considered
active and the flow associated with that
page
is considered active as well every flow
has a special start page
when a flow initially becomes active the
start page becomes the current page
and depending on where the user is in
the conversation
the current page will either stay the
same or transition
to another page now let's understand
pages
think of pages in cx as web pages when
we fill the fields in the form
on a web page and submit it we receive a
corresponding response
similarly a page in cx has a form that
is configured to collect
information or parameters from the end
users
this information is relevant to the
conversation state
on that page transition routes decide
where we want to route the user
from the current page now let's see this
in our pugs use case in the cx console
i've created an agent already to explain
these concepts but don't worry
we will be creating this agent from
scratch in the next episode
for now if we go in the order flow we
see the start page which will become
active when the order flow triggers
and routes to the collect information
page which collects the parameters
shoe size and the color and routes the
customer to the confirmation page
if the user confirms we end the flow
with the end flow page
and if the user does not confirm then
the page
routes them back to the collect
information page to capture those
parameters of shoe sizes and the color
for more details on the life cycle of a
page i've added the links in the
description
the transition routes would depend on
intents which represents something
our users want to do during a
conversation with our agent
for example here in puns order flow the
start page has a transition route to
order intent
where we expect the user to provide us
the size and the color of the shoe they
want to
buy here we also add the multiple
training example phrases
for what customers might type or say
depending on what they say the intents
are matched appropriately
and the parameter values are extracted
such as the size and the color of the
shoe
now if you've used dialogflow essentials
then i want to point out here that the
intents in cx have been simplified to
make them
more reusable resource going back to the
parameters
they have a name and entity type
entities are used to control
how data from the end user input is
extracted
so here the sys dot color is a system
entity that refers to color
and size is a custom entity that refers
to the shoe size
now back to the page for a second if the
transition route from the page
leads to a form where we collect some
parameters from the user
we need to either do something with
these parameters or provide the user
with the response
in pog's case we call the order intent
and have the user provide us with the
size and color of the shoes
then in the collect information page we
check the condition
if both of these pieces of information
are collected
and only then we route to the
confirmation page
until then we stay on the page to get
those pieces of information
on the confirmation page we actually get
back to the user
using the fulfillment here i've added
the static text
but this would ideally be a dynamic text
based on the information coming from
pugs back end
through a webhook alright so that was a
quick summary of how pages and
transitions
work in dialogflow cx along with a
glimpse of the pugs virtual agent
now that all the foundational
information is out of the way
i am excited for the next episode where
we will start
building the pugs conversational
experience in dialogflow cx
until then comment below to let me know
your thoughts on this episode
you